j - 18 avant les élections
départementales il est l'heure d'ouvrir
notre journal de campagne
on sent millions bonsoir on commence
cette page avec des conseils pour aller
voter oui on parle beaucoup d'une
abstention qui s'annonce forte et bien
pour lutter un peu contre le phénomène
les services de l'état rappellent que
pour ces élections départementales le
vote par procuration est possible
reportage de françois latour et
jean-françois guilmard voter est un
devoir civique et l'état met à
disposition des électeurs le vote par
procuration pour tous ceux qui ne
pourront pas déposer dans l'urne leur
bulletin le jour du scrutin
que ce soit pour des raisons
professionnelles ou personnelles la
démarche est quand même suffisamment
simple pour elle était en plus
simplifiée par la possibilité de
télécharger le formulaire de vote par
procuration sur internet
ce qui n'empêche toutefois pas
l'obligation pour le mans dont c'est à
dire les lecteurs qui ne sera pas
présent le jour du scrutin de se
déplacer auprès des autorités
compétentes pour délivrer le document
c'est à dire le tribunal d'instance
l'hôtel de police et les commissariats
ainsi que les brigades de gendarmerie
soit du lieu de résidence soit du lieu
de travail
vous devez déposer votre formulaire en
personne avec une pièce d'identité
il n'est pas nécessaire de justifier
votre absence la démarche est gratuite
et rapide
à condition de ne pas se tromper de
mandataire vous devez être inscrit tous
les deux dans la même commune de même
pas plus d'une procuration par personnes
famille amis ou voisins le choix vous
appartient
attention il ne reste que deux semaines
avant le scrutin en revanche pour les
consignes de vote
vous avez encore tout votre temps et
comme à chaque soir lilian notre gros
plan sur un canton
oui nous avons choisi le canton de saint
vallier en saône et loire qui se
caractérise par une lutte fratricide
entre le ps et le front de gauche un
phénomène déjà observé aux municipales
accentuée par le contexte national est
amplifiée ici par le redécoupage
électoral puisque ce canton est le
regroupement des anciens canton de
montceau sud et toulon sur arroux et
comme partout le front national affiche
de fortes ambitions
un portage de michel gillot gabrielle
talon et cécile claveau
cravate rouge alain philibert annonce la
couleur dans le canton de saint vallier
l'union ps pc a vécu si le maire est
candidat fait avec son binôme aida
berger une campagne de proximité
s'il rappelle volontiers son attachement
aux missions de solidarité du conseil
départemental
reste que son discours le plus fort vise
surtout le parti socialiste au pouvoir
moi je me reconnais pas dans la
politique menée par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui et je me reconnais pas dans
la politique que les socialistes
soutiennent et ça je ne peux pas être de
cette gauche là moi je suis vraiment au
service de l'humain toujours et je ne
comprends pas vous savez on avait dit le
changement c'est maintenant et on était
profondément déçu cette quasi rupture le
ps jean-claude lagrange ne l'assument
pas aussi volontiers je ne considère pas
l'adversaire ni contre alain philibert
et lequel on peut travailler
on aurait pu faire un accord je lé
souhaitait avec des élus de saint
vallier les appareils n'ont pas l'eau
pas forcément souhaité je trouve que
c'est dommage pour ce scrutin le maire
de sanvignes et conseiller régional veut
éviter de trop incarner le ps au pouvoir
pour hélène officier lui la campagne est
donc résolument centrée sur les
compétences de l'assemblée
départementale
c'est aussi une façon pense-t-il de
redonner du crédit à une fonction
politique déconsidéré on sent bien qu un
projet de politique un peu facilement
mais tous les élus dans le même sac que
rien ne va plus en france cetera on
rencontre aussi des gens qui ne sont pas
forcément aussi aussi marqué par cette
ambiance et qui comprennent les enjeux
locaux quand on la parle de petite
enfance ou de maisons de retraite sait
bien que c'est pas la question de la loi
mâcon qui va régler ça
un lotissement de saint vallier boîte
aux lettres après boîte aux lettres
élection après élection le front
national avance pas question pour la
candidate anne sophie sur gala
d'argumenter sur la politique sociale du
département ou sur les collèges
ce qui compte pour le fn c'est de
poursuivre sa progression électorale
dans tous les cas nous suivrons la même
ligne qu'elles soient communales qu'elle
soit départementales ou bien national en
sachant que nous tenons de toute façon à
garder nos départements tout simplement
à les défendre
nous pouvons de toute façon on espérait
un bon nombre de voix voilà avoisinants
de toute façon les 30-35 %
c'est le résultat que vous escomptez sur
ce canton absolument
il est vrai que le rural réussit plutôt
bien aux fn et rural ce canton redessine
elle est en grande partie
nous sommes ici à perrecy les forges
1700 habitants la ruralité caroline se
ti et de nibaudeau en fonte lax forts de
leur campagne
mais pour ce binôme ump la candidature
du front national est une vraie menace
et il ne ménage pas cet adversaire qui
dit il se trompe d'élection
moi je vois je viens de connaître de
découvrir les représentants du front
national on a quelqu'un qui est
parachuté de louhans je sais pas du tout
ce qui connaît notre canton son binôme
nous fait de la politique de sécurité
sur des compétences qui appartiennent
aux collectivités locales parce que la
sécurité de la police municipale sa part
tient la mer et entre de saint-vallier
mais ça n'appartient pas au conseil
général
donc je crois qu'ils se trompent de
discours avec deux binômes rivaux à
gauche le canton de saint vallier est
symptomatique des difficultés du ps a
rassemblé cela pourrait-il se solder ici
par une gauche absente du second tour
l'hypothèse ne peut pas être écartée
voilà des candidats qui bat la campagne
mais qui s'appuie aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux de tout ce que vous avez péché
aujourd'hui sur internet
pas de menottes je vous rassure mais une
sélection qui vous montre les différents
usages des réseaux sociaux d'abord il y
a le candidat dans la vraie vie comme la
socialiste nathalie koenders de dijon ii
au soutien des ducs l'équipe de hockey
sur glace de dijon au bord de la glace
ensuite il ya le candidat qui nous
montrent qu'ils bossent fabien bazin
candidats à corbigny dans la nièvre et
maire de lormes s'occupe d'une
transmission d'entreprises dans le monde
rural
pendant que jean baptiste lemoyne
candidat de droite dans le gâtinais dans
l'yonne nous rappelle au passage qu'il
est aussi sénateur avec une photo d'une
commission du sénat dans laquelle il
siège
et puis il ya les arguments de campagne
déclinée sur ces réseaux sociaux julien
odoul candidat front national à
pont-sur-yonne exposé photos du village
de ville perreault à l'appui sa vision
de l'identité nationale je le cite
église mais
monument aux morts pendant que la
socialiste chalonnaise françoise
verjux-pelletier dégaine carrément le
tableau avant après sur les places en
maisons de retraite dans le département
créé par les majorités de droite puis de
gauche en saône et loire
tout ça est assez sérieux c'est toujours
le cas sur twitter non bien sûr on peut
aussi sourire avec andré gervais
candidats avec céline maglica sur le
canton de dijon 6 qui vous montrent que
l'expression porte la porte veut
vraiment dire portes après porte et
toutes les portes ne s'ouvrent pas tout
le temps et puis bien sûr il ya les
traditionnels selphy l'ump laurent
bourguignat avec virginie voisins dans
le quartier de la toison d'or à dijon
c'est à dire le nouveau canton de dijon
3 et puis toujours un côte d'or jean
philippe morel candidats udi sur le
canton de longvic qui a profité du
soleil avec son équipe de tractage voilà
c'est terminé pour ce soir et demain
vont venir ni hao servent au quotidien